I'm in Colombo, the largest and capital city
of the island of Sri Lanka.
It's a vibrant and colorful city of about
6 million inhabitants.
Today, we're going to cruise around and check
out a few of the fun things to do around Colombo!
The first stop is Pettah, Colombo's largest
and most chaotic market.
So, I am at the Pettah market right now, which
is in the center of Colombo city and I'm about
to go check out this hectic market.
Ok, guys, I am in the back of a tuk tuk rickshaw
in Colombo, Sri Lanka and I'm going on a little
tour around some of the famous sites in Colombo.
Gangamaraya Temple is not only one of the
most important Buddhist temples in Colombo,
but it's also a museum that is full of religious
relics.
On the street just outside the Viharamahadevi
Park there are a couple of snake charmers.
I'm at Independence Monument in Colombo, it's
dedicated to the first Prime Minister of Sri
Lanka - and it's a pretty cool site.
I happened to be in Colombo during the Hindu
Diwali festival, so it was interesting to
catch a live ceremony at the Sri Kailasanathar
Swami Devasthanam Hindu Temple.
On our way to the next stop, we got into a
little rickshaw face-off - luckily we came
through in first place!
After a long hot day of cruising around Colombo,
I'm extremely hungry and I'm ready to chow
down.
Galle Face on the beach is one of the best
places for street food in town.
I'm about to chow down at Nana fast food - I'm
excited, I just ordered up a bunch of different
dishes including some fish curry.
Let me grab a piece of that and dip it into
this fish curry - that's really good man!
It's a little bit sweet, spicy, it's nice
tasting.
And then the Kottu - it's like fried rice
made with root.
It's wonderful.
I can taste the friedness on it, mixed with
the vegetables, it's fantastic.
Stuffed from a delicious Sri Lankan feast,
it's time to jump on a wild Sri Lankan bus
and call it a successful day in Colombo!